thank you thank you very much this week
America continues our aggressive effort
to defeat the virus as we enter a
crucial and difficult phase of the
battle we continue to send our prayers
to the people of New York and New Jersey
and to our whole country but right now
in New York and New Jersey are very hot
zones and well with them were with
everybody your struggle is our struggle
and we will beat this virus we will beat
it together I also want to send best
wishes to a very good friend of mine and
a friend to our nation Prime Minister
Boris Johnson
we're very saddened to hear that he was
taken into intensive care this afternoon
a little while ago and Americans are all
praying for his recovery he's been a
really good friend he's been really
something very special strong resolute
doesn't quit doesn't give up we have
made tremendous progress on therapeutics
I had a fantastic call today which I'll
be talking about a little bit later and
I've asked two of the leading companies
is a brilliant company's Ebola AIDS
others they've come with the solutions
and just have done incredible jobs and
I've asked them to contact London
immediately they have offices in London
the major companies but more than major
more than sighs their genius and I had a
talk with four of them today and they
speak a language that most people don't
even understand but I understand
something that they've really advanced
therapeutics and therapeutically and
they have arrived in London already the
London office has whatever they need and
we'll see if we can be of help we've
contacted all of
Boris's doctors and we'll see what is
going to take place but they are ready
to go but when you get brought into
intensive care that gets very very
serious with this particular disease so
the two companies are there and with
what they are talking about and it's
rather complex and and has had really
incredible results we're working with
the FDA and everybody else but we are
working with London with respect to
Boris Johnson across the country we're
attacking the enemy on all fronts
including medical scientific social
logistical and economic we're pressing
into action the full power of American
government and American enterprise and
our military has been incredible we've
just sent 3,000 public health personnel
they're now deployed in the New York
area and they'll be over at the Javits
Center over at the the great ship and as
you probably have heard and I was
informed that Governor Cuomo has already
told you and announced he called me up a
little while ago and he asked whether or
not it would be possible to use the ship
with respect to fighting the virus and
we hadn't had that in mind at all but
we're going to let him do it and we're
also going to let New Jersey Governor
Murphy we spoke with him a little while
ago and New Jersey is going to use it
also because New Jersey is a hot a hot
spot so governor Murphy and Governor
Cuomo are going to be using ship from
New York New Jersey and it's a big ship
and it's now covet
it's set for covet and we are going to
hopefully that will be very helpful to
both the states the Javits Center which
is 2,900 beds just built by our military
also is going to be manned now by the
military and they should be in place
tomorrow and they'll start sending quite
a few people over to the Javits Center
it's convenient it's right in the middle
of everything so that'll be something
great and we appreciate it governor
cuomo's nice really nice statements and
likewise governor Murphy we have worked
very well with both of them and with
frankly all of the governor's vice
president pence had a call this morning
with them that lasted for close to two
hours and I understand there wasn't a
negative person on the call 50 governors
or just about 50 governors I think they
were all on from what I understood and
they were very positive about everything
their federal government has been doing
for them and you'll hear what that is
and it's it's rather amazing actually
nationwide the Army Corps of Engineers
is building 22 field hospitals these are
big hospitals and altered at care sites
in 18 states so you have a combination
of 22 field hospitals in addition to
that we're building alternate care sites
which is a little bit of a smaller
version of the hospital and we have a
lot of them and they're going up in 18
different states in total we've deployed
8450 hospital beds from federal Sauk
Wales and you know if you think this has
done over a period of really a period of
weeks it's incredible actually more than
8,000 ventilators have been sent from
the national stockpile to our cities and
states backed by the defense production
Act which we've used very strongly very
powerfully so powerfully that we don't
have to use it too much frankly and it's
nice to when you don't have to we're
getting more than we ever bargained for
American industry is stepping up
manufacturers are really going to town
and we have thousands of ventilators
being built as we speak and we have
hundreds that are being sent to
different locations and we're ready to
roll with almost 10,000 that we have in
the federal stockpile
when I say ready to roll - I mean
exactly what that states we are wherever
that monster goes were able to move with
it great flexibility we have tremendous
flexibility and we have people waiting
and they're ready willing and able but
waiting to bring them wherever it may be
if they need it
if they need it it's possible that they
won't be needed that we're fully stocked
because numbers are coming in where
because of what the American people are
doing we're having fewer hospital visits
I think that could be the case in New
York it could be the case in a few other
states and fewer beds fewer hospital
visits mean fewer ventilators so we'll
see whether or not our original
projections were right but anyway I had
a very good talk with both governors and
I think they're very happy extremely
happy about the what we're doing for
them and especially going all kovat so
that'll take place almost immediately
FEMA and HHS have directly distributed
eleven point seven million and ninety
five respirators think of that get the
number eleven point seven million n95
respirators eleven point seven million
twenty six point five million surgical
masks 5.3 million face shields four
point four million
surgical gowns and twenty-two point six
million gloves twenty-two point six
million laughs we have also arranged for
vast quantities of additional materials
to be allocated through donations and
existing supply chains we've also given
tremendous medical materiel and supplies
throughout the 50 states and territories
and through project air bridge we have
succeeded in bringing plane loads of
vital supplies into the United States
from overseas we had an additional three
these are massive planes by the way the
big planes very big very powerful and
that
loaded to the gills with supplies and
rather than bringing them into our
stockpile as we've discussed we bring
them to all the different locations
where they're needed so we can save a
big step and a timely step because of my
actions under the DPA I can also
announce today that we have reached an
agreement very amicable agreement with
3m for the delivery of an additional 50
5.5 million high quality face masks face
masks each month so that we're going to
be getting over the next couple of
months one hundred and sixty six point
five million masks for our frontline
health care workers so the 3m saga ends
very happily we're very proud to be
dealing now with 3m and it's a CEO Mike
Roman I just spoke with him and I
thanked him for getting it done and Mike
was very happy to get it done great
company so we're getting one hundred and
sixty six point five million masks and
mostly that's going to be for our
frontline health care workers okay
that's 3m thank you 3m I also want to
thank Apple one of the many great
American companies that's taken into
that you are leptin to action today
Apple announced that it is now producing
plastic face shields for healthcare
workers at the rate of 1 million per
week 1 million and these are the shields
that you see on television quite a bit
and they're at the highest level of
quality and safety we're grateful as
well to Salesforce which has donated 48
million pieces of personal protective
equipment including masks gowns suits
and face shields so thank you very much
to Salesforce I urge all of our nation's
governor's to ensure that the massive
deliveries that we've made to your
states over the past few weeks are
distributed as quickly as possible so
again we're working very well with the
governor's now they may see you and say
we're not happy but they're very happy
on the phone and Mike Pence is a
straight shooter and he had a great
phone conversation to them with all of
the governor conference and they're very
happy every one of them were there any
negatives see I told you Mike is the
greatest Mike and you have done a great
job Mike and I appreciate the whole
country appreciates it if they
appreciate this right don't you see
everybody appreciates Mike special man
so a lot of the things that we've done
again are going directly to the states
the state seem to be very happy if
they're not they can call me directly
they can call Mike directly and we'll
make them happy but tremendous progress
has been made in a very short period and
I think very importantly the progress
has been made before the surge comes
because the next week week-and-a-half is
going to be a big surge the
professionals tell us and I think we're
in good shape for Dan theny so it's good
timing really good timing we can have
this stuff they are it's already there
for the most part but we're bringing a
lot of different resources to to the
various locations especially where the
surge is looking like it's going to take
place resources from the national
stockpile need to reach our warriors and
they are warriors I tell it all the time
I saw it again this morning
he's young in many cases many cases
older but they're walking into the
hospital and they're putting on yeah I
mean as their doors open they're going
into this place and you know it's not
exactly too safe and they're going in
there and they're putting the outfits on
them they're putting their masks on and
they're it's incredible it's don't it's
early it's like no different then you
watch the war movies you watch the old
clips of war running up hills to me it's
the same thing men and women young and
old but a lot of young people just going
in there they're not thinking about oh
gee this is dangerous they're not saying
well I don't want to go in there
warriors they're running through those
doors it's the most incredible thing
it's so beautiful it's incredible
beautiful thing resources from the
national stockpile need to reach these
warriors in the hospitals immediately
and we're making sure they do
and again the states have that
responsibility but we're working with
the states and we're getting the states
a lot of things that they could
distribute or when they tell us we bring
it directly to the hospital from the
federal stockpile or from the planes
that land which without even going to
the stockpile if any states having
difficulty distributing supplies we urge
you to use the National Guard to assist
in the delivery and I have to say you
have done a fantastic job Deborah you
know that you've done great Tony you
know that you've done great but what a
job you've done and I appreciate it I
really do your whole group has been
incredible that's a lot of stars you
have a bounty of that he's supposed to
do a great job when you have four stars
right but the military has been
incredible and I thank them for all of
us
conversely if a state believes that it
has surplus equipment or supplies very
important because we actually have
gotten so much to some of the states
that they're able to now they've done a
fantastic job and they've kept they've
kept that line low and we have some
states that have surplus equipment and
supplies and they're working with us to
rapidly redeploy those supplies to areas
of greatest need we thought that might
happen if it worked out well that's what
was going to happen and it's happening
and I want to thank governor Gavin
Newsom who is doing a tremendous job was
announced California will send 500
ventilators to be distributed to other
locations I think some are going to
Arizona some are going to Washington do
you see we think they're going to tell
what we're working through that but 500
excess ventilators from the state of
California and we're going to get them
taken care of wherever they have to go
those decisions are being made right now
the members of the White House Task
Force and I are in close touch
mayors and governors and hospital
administrators across our country and
we're told that the present time at the
present time most of the critical needs
are are being more than met states have
to continue sharing detailed information
in the amount and utilization rates of
medical supplies so we know what to
resupply them or they can get it
directly that includes ventilators they
can get it directly ideally if they can
get it directly but if they can't if
they're unable to do it we have
tremendous amounts of supplies that
we're building it up very fast too
and this is before the big search this
information is fundamental to our
ability to deliver the material when
when and where it's most needed now Mike
in his conversation today I think got
some information as to a couple of
locations where we're going to be
delivering large numbers of ventilators
and large numbers of medical supplies
and we'll take care of that but some of
the states are very happy even governor
Pritzker from Illinois is happy because
he may not be happy when he talks to the
press but he's happy he's a very happy
man we're increasingly hopeful that the
aggressive mitigation strategy we put
into place will ultimately allow our
hospital system to successfully manage
the major influx of cases that that we
have right now again I say that we're
finding because of the incredible job
done by the American people in
conjunction with everybody governor's
the military federal government state
government local government had a lot of
conversations with New York City and
mayor de Blasio I've gotten to know him
I didn't know him gotten to know him and
a lot of people are working hard
everybody's working are a lot of people
are doing a great job tell you that a
lot of people are doing a great job but
the goal is that all Americans have been
sacrificing to achieve these last few
weeks things that a lot of people
thought were not possible to it
Eve and I think we've more than achieved
but we have to go through again we're
gonna have a rough week we're gonna have
maybe a rough little more than a week
and but this tremendous light at the end
of that tunnel I said it last time said
it last night there's tremendous light
at the end of the tunnel there's so many
things happening with therapeutics with
vaccines with things that we really want
deborah tony they're all working so hard
on this but those therapeutics I mean
look the vaccines are going to be always
a little bit later because of that
testing period but the therapeutics
getting the kind of things that I heard
about today talking to these brilliant
companies and brilliant people on the
phone was fantastic was such an
incredible conversation and I also spoke
just a few minutes ago with vice
president former Vice President Biden
who called and we had a really wonderful
warm conversation was a very nice
conversation we talked about pretty much
this this is what we talked about this
is what everyone's talking about this is
what they want to talk about and he gave
me his point of view and I fully
understood that and we just had a very
friendly conversation lasted probably 15
minutes and it was really good it was
really good really nice I think it was
very much so I appreciate his calling as
we continue our efforts to develop
treatments and cures this afternoon I
spoke with leaders of the American
pharmaceutical companies and just to
give you their names
Amgen Genentech Gilead Regeneron these
are for the greatest in the world for
doing exactly what they're doing and
currently ten different therapeutic
agents are in active trials and some are
looking incredibly successful but we
have to go through a process and it's
going to be a fairly quick process I
will tell you based on what the FDA told
me and another 15 are in plans for
clinical trials so they're advancing
rapidly and today a second company
announced
that the FDA has authorized its vaccine
candidate to begin clinical trials see
if Johnson & Johnson is already there I
believe they're the one that's first and
now we have a second company that just
just announced and we were just was just
approved so we have two companies at
that level for the vaccine it's uh we've
now performed 100 well if you think of
this 1.79 million tests that's 1 million
seven hundred and ninety thousand tests
nationwide and I think we're gonna put
up a screen here someplace that they're
1q but just don't Q and here it is this
is the process starting on 5 March and
ending right there
right about now right that's about it so
and it's going up at a rapid rate nobody
has done more testing and one of the
reasons why they say and I I think I can
say this Deborah very strongly but one
of the reasons that we have more cases
is we've done more cat more testing if I
went to some of these countries that
have in my opinion far more people than
we do that had the problem and if we did
the kind of testing proportionately that
would do it they'd have many more cases
than us but we have more cases because
we do much more testing so when you do
the testing you have cases otherwise you
would know about the cases people sit
home you don't know about it but we have
now done 1 million seven hundred ninety
thousand tests nationwide that's more
than any other country in the world
hence we have more cases and that number
is growing by nearly 125,000 people per
day think of that one so it's growing by
one hundred and twenty five thousand
people per day I told you about South
Korea this is a you know vastly faster
and we also have they say the most
accurate of tests CBS is launching and
they've been great too new drive-through
testing sites in Atlanta Georgia and
Providence Rhode Island
and each location would be able to test
up to 1,000 patients per day using the
ultra-fast five-minute test developed by
Abbott Labs now they're down to five
minute they go the ultra-fast and it's
very accurate Abbott Labs I want to
thank them they've been fantastic
we're also speeding urgent economic
relief to the American worker and
families and the employers as of today
tens of thousands of small businesses
are applied for more than forty billion
dollars in relief under the Paycheck
protection program you've all been
reading about it and it's really I mean
it's only been going for a couple of
days it's really been performing well a
couple of little glitches minor glitches
that have already been taken care of
what they say these funds were resulted
nearly 2 million jobs being preserved so
we're taking care of our workers small
businesses and our workers nearly 3,000
lenders have already made loans under
the program and we're signing up
additional lenders very quickly rapidly
community banks have been very
responsive and larger banks are also
stepping up
if this prongs by the way we're already
preparing because it's going so fast for
the small businesses and their employees
will ask Congress to refill it
immediately but the banks have been
great the big banks the Bank of America
was right up there at the beginning
JPMorgan Chase was was has been great
they after the first day they really
they really came through and a lot of
the big banks but the community banks
have been fantastic as we announced last
week we are providing 100 billion
dollars in direct support for our
hospitals and the first tranche 30
billion dollars will be distributed this
week so I want to want to say one other
thing our farmers we love our farmers
and as you know as of April 1st the
China trade deal 250 billion dollar they
purchased two hundred and fifty billion
dollars from us if not more and of that
approximately 50 billion is expected to
be with our farmers so
it kicked in as of April first and we'll
see how it goes it seems like they're
buying so we'll let you know how that's
going but they're buying anywhere from
forty to fifty billion dollars worth of
our agricultural product that it should
have a huge impact on our farmers a
tremendous impact on our farmers but
we're watching it very closely to fight
the medical war we've mobilized the
unbeatable and it just it is unbeatable
strength of American determination
ingenuity and compassion I got to see
that when I spoke to the great science
because I call them science companies
more than drug companies they're
scientists we've seen businesses
charities and private citizens making
generous donations so many people are
making donations we've seen states and
cities supporting and helping each other
and caring for our citizens and we've
seen Americans of all backgrounds and
beliefs uniting together to answer the
challenge and rise to the moment and
that's what they're doing above all
we've been awed and inspired by the
exceptional courage of the doctors
nurses EMTs and health care workers who
are the soldiers of this war no words
can ever express the complete measure of
our gratitude for these intrepid heroes
one Cleveland patient credited his
medical team for not only saving his
life through their skill but forever
changing his life through their example
of selfless devotion couldn't believe
it's so generous he was with his
statements and he talked about their
bravery in an area that was in such
trouble an area of that hospital where
people were dying and he talked about
their bravery another survivor in
Houston said simply I will consider them
my angels forever I will consider them
think of that my angels forever as our
nation endures the depths of loss and
grief
we are also witness to the summit of
American virtue character and courage
with the love and dedication of every
American patriot we will win this battle
we will defeat this enemy and we
we'll rise from this present crisis with
new strength unity and resolve and
that's what's happening tremendous
stories are coming out of this horrible
moment very dark moment for the world
182 I was saying 151 for a while and
then it got up to 160 and it's 182 as I
announced yesterday hundred and eighty
two countries are being attacked by this
virus so I just want to thank everybody
I want to thank the American citizens
for doing a great job stay inside and
let's win this and let's get our country
open as soon as we can I think it's
going to be sooner than people think
things are going really well again light
at the end of the tunnel and with that
I'll take a few questions and then Mike
is going to take over and talk with the
Admiral and with the professionals and
we appreciate you being here yes please
mention things we're asking good drug
companies provide treatment to the
British prime minister what sort of
treatment is that well it's very yeah
it's a very complex treatment of things
that they've just recently developed and
that they have a lot of experience with
having to do with something else but
recent for this and they'll be they've
already concurred they've already had
meetings with the doctors and we'll see
whether or not they want to go that
route but when you're an intensive care
it's a big deal so they're there and
they're ready I think we have we have
three over we spoke with four you know
who the four would be and you know the
people within those you probably you'd
know the companies I told you the
companies but the people at the greatest
the greatest in the world so they're at
the hospital and we'll see and they have
they have everything with them should it
be needed hopefully hopefully we won't
have to be needed but should it be
needed I just I found him I found Boris
to be a fantastic person just like a
fantastic warm strong smart guy he loves
his country you see that I mean he
fought like like hell for his country
and intensive care is big stuff really
big stuff yesterday you were asked about
this as well but now that you can move
to intensive care does that give you and
the vice president any pause or
additional concerns steps that you're
taking to preserve the continuity of
government here no I don't think so Mike
had his test a couple of days ago I had
my test couple of days ago so and we're
here and here you are so no I don't
think so but I think we'll probably just
because of questions like that I think
we'll probably have maybe quite a few
tests it's not the worst idea you know
the system of testing that was so quick
and so easy so I could see and you were
tested again today nearly 1.8 million
tests that you say the United States has
done the Inspector General for the
Department of Health and Human Services
released a report today a survey of more
than 300 hospitals across the country
and the number one complaint from those
hospitals were severe shortages of
testing supplies and did I hear the word
Inspector General really it's wrong and
they'll talk to you about it it's wrong
it's well where did he come from the
inspector general what's his name it
came from the inspector what's his merit
I don't know his name well I'm using it
let me know okay let you find me his
name I'd appreciate it but sir these are
all I can tell you is this
and put up on the board you're gonna ask
give a nasty Admiral but we are doing to
get there we've done more testing and
had more results than any country
anywhere in the world they're doing an
incredible job now they're all calling
us they want our testing what are we
doing how do you do the five minute test
how do you do the 15 minute test so give
me the name of the inspector general
could politics be entered into that go
ahead please come in thank you sir are
you worried about retaliation to your
decision to ban export of medical Goods
like Indian Prime
Moody's decision to not export hydrogen
hydroxychloroquine to the United States
no other country I don't like that
decision if that's I don't I didn't hear
that that was his decision I know that
he stopped it for other countries I
spoke to him yesterday we had a very
good talk and we'll see whether or not
that says I would be surprised if he
would you know because India's does very
well with the United States for many
years they've been taken advantage of
the United States on trade so I would be
surprised of that worse decision he'd
have to tell me that I spoke to him
Sunday morning called him and I said we
would appreciate your allowing our
supply to come out if he doesn't allow
it to come out that would be okay but of
course there may be retaliation why
wouldn't there be mr. president the
Paycheck protection program had gotten
off to a confusing start for small Wells
Fargo has stopped taking applications
Bank of America and not any more than
prioritize taking applications from
clients that were already thank you for
the leader taken tremendous numbers of
applications and of course there may
have been they wanted to have a slightly
different application they wanted to
have a little different information but
Bank of America has been a leader they
number one in terms of applications
I wish you'd asked the question
differently why don't you say it's
gotten off to a tremendous start but
there are some little glitches which by
the way have been worked out there would
be so much nicer if you do that but
you're just incapable of asking a
question in a positive way it's taking
the measures it's taken the measures and
we may even do a different system not
with this we're gonna have to probably
add more money to this to save and to
keep our small businesses going and to
keep the employees of those small
businesses working but it's such a
positive event and you ask it in such a
negative way it's just I wish I wish we
had a fair media in this country and we
really don't
speaking of unfair
mr. president the Acting Secretary of
the Navy told the crew of the USS
Roosevelt that captain Crozier went
either quote too naive or too stupid to
be in command is it appropriate for the
chief officer named is he speaking his
way about this captain well I haven't
heard it exactly I haven't heard I heard
they had a statement that was made if
that were the statement it's a strong
statement look the letters shouldn't
have been sent and certainly they
shouldn't have been leaked this is a
military operation I must tell you I've
heard very good things about the
gentleman both gentlemen by the way I
will say this but about both gentlemen
and I may look into it only from the
standpoint that something should be
resolved because I'm hearing good things
about both people I may just get
involved if it's okay with you yeah
because you know you have two good
people and they're arguing and I'm good
believe it or not at settling arguments
I'm good at settling these arguments so
I may look into it in great detail in
detail and I'll be able to figure it out
very fast but that was a statement it's
a rough statement but look look letters
should not have been sent to many people
unclassified that was a mistake
it's a mistake that shouldn't have been
made because it's unfair to the families
of the people on the ship because they
get nervous and it shows weakness and
there's nothing weak about us now not
anymore
we have the strongest military we've
ever had and we're not going to be
showing weakness to anybody because we
have that ship is incredible
nuclear-powered aircraft carrier and we
don't want to be doing writing letters
we don't want to have letter-writing
campaigns where the fake news finds a
letter or gets a leak we don't want that
so the letter excuse me
so the letter shouldn't have been sent
with all of that said his career prior
to that was very good so I'm gonna get
involved and see exactly what's going on
there because I don't want to destroy
somebody for having a bad day okay does
that make sense
okay mr. president Vice President
Biden's spokesperson said that he made
some suggestions to you about actions
that you could be taken he deal with the
pandemic we had a very good talk we
agreed that we weren't going to talk
about what we said but we had a very
very good talk there was a warm talk I
enjoyed it I hope he enjoyed it too and
he was short it was 15 minutes you're
going to get suggestions it doesn't mean
that I agree with those suggestions but
certainly had suggestions and I also
told him some of the things we're doing
but the conversation was a a friendly
very friendly conversation yeah thanks a
lot mr. president you've mentioned other
members of your task force have
mentioned over the course of the next
two weeks it's going to be a very
difficult time for our country in terms
of fatalities and there it will be a
difficult weekend have and there are a
number of Governors who are close allies
of yours mr. president who have
refrained thus far to have these stay at
home orders and doctor Falchi who of
courses while you're your task force has
said that drew it would the states that
don't have stay at home orders are
putting themselves at risk and the
country doctor foul she said that I
would be inclined to call them up you
know we do have a constitutional problem
in doing that you understand that I mean
there's a double there's a double that
you understand I can do it but it is a
constitution where you can say
Federalists you can say there's lots of
different reasons where I would rather
have the governors do it make their own
determination they're smaller and not in
all cases but sort of this Waller cases
but I'm not sure 100% that doctor foul
she said that but you can ask please I
had I have good conversations with the
governor of Nebraska and the governor of
Iowa here and it's it's interesting that
functionally even though they have not
given a strict say at home what they are
doing is really functionally equivalent
to that and we had a really good
conversation with with both of the
governors and and that it you know when
I hadn't mentioned that I think there
was a public response that they weren't
really doing anything at all and they
really are doing a very good job both of
them those are the only two that I spoke
to
but it was a really good conversation
and I want to make sure people
understand that just because they don't
have a very strict stay at home order
they haven't placed a lot of things that
are totally compatible with what
everyone else is doing um
about getting back to normal you said
you wanted to get back to normal as soon
as possible will we truly get back to
normal in this country before there's an
actual vaccine that's available to
everybody what in how do you how do you
start lifting the restrictions yeah what
will John if back to normal means acting
like there never was a coronavirus
problem I don't think that's gonna
happen until we do have a situation
where you can completely protect the
population but when we say getting back
to normal we mean something very
different from what we're going through
right now because right now we are in a
very intense mitigation when we get back
to normal we will go back gradually to
the point where we can function as a
society but you're absolutely right
I mean if you want to get to pre corona
virus you know that might not ever
happen in the sense of the the fact that
the threat is there but I believe with
the therapies that will be coming online
and with the fact that I feel confident
that over a period of time we will get a
good vaccine that we will never have to
get back to where we are right back now
so if that means getting back to normal
then we'll get back to normal with the
vaccines which I have total confidence
are coming and I'm dealing with the
companies I'm talking to Johnson &
Johnson I'm talking to all of them I
think that when you add the tremendous
stimulus that we're giving
like for instance deductibility for
restaurant expenses for restaurants and
entertainment the money that we're
talking about for small businesses and
employees to keep everybody working and
other things that we're frankly working
on right now which are going to be great
for our people I think when you add that
to it I think we could get more than
back to normal from an economic sample
it actually be better but more than back
to normal but I I would agree that would
love to see a vaccine but immediately we
would love to see a therapeutic and I
think we're getting very close
be able to lift restrictions on April
30th right now I want to comment on that
but I can tell you that we certainly
want to try we certainly want to see
what what's going on we're doing very
well look you look at those you look at
most places with that you can call it
the bump you could call it the hill you
can call it the mountain you can call
whatever you want to do it it's very
flat you take a look and that was done
through a mitigation that was done
through a lot of good work and that far
exceeded our expectations before I mean
you people can't even believe how how
low some of those bumps are some of
those hills are they're very surprised
they have a couple of tough ones New
Jersey's been very tough in New York has
been very tough they're crowded in you
know it's tight it's tougher but we far
exceeding California far exceeds
Washington state far exceeds you look at
so many of these states how well they're
doing the eight states by the way and I
haven't spoken to the governor's but
Tony's so right
they may not have it from the standpoint
that they're saying it but those people
are practicing it and they're doing a
fantastic job take a look at where they
are in terms of the levels but take a
look where they are so but if I thought
it was something that and I've looked at
him and I've looked at him very
carefully looked at him today looked at
him yesterday from a constitutional
standpoint I'd love not to get involved
with it and not from a legal standpoint
just from a moral constitutional
standpoint because legally I can but
morally you know I believe in our
Constitution much more so than most
people and I'd love to be able to let
the governors do what they have to do
those states are doing a fantastic job
all eight of them they're doing a
fantastic job so we'll see what happens
as for your question you fully
understand what I'm saying so thank you
hi two minutes if I may welcome somebody
outside the room of first cast gun do
you think Boris Johnson he talked about
possible patients did he downplay the
threat of this virus too much and do you
know exactly what this car I think Boris
was looking at it differently he was
looking at it earlier he was looking at
it like write it out there were many
people thinking about writing it out
meaning you know whatever it is it is
but then you see what starts to happen
and the numbers become monumental and
they decide not to do that we actually
moved early we moved early because of
what we did with respect to the ban on
China coming in and then Europe coming
in that was an early band 2 and then UK
so no he waited a little while and he he
felt that but he got you know he made a
decision very quickly thereafter to do
what they did and they they've gone
through a very strict lockdown but this
suffering greatly as a nation right now
they're going through a lot you know
they're they're a nation that's having a
difficult time but I've gotten to know
him he's just such an incredible guy was
just so shocking to say that because you
know what that means intensive care is a
big deal with regard to what we're
talking about that's a very big deal
very scary deal yeah question it's
thomas Howell of The Washington Times
how many health workers in the US have
become infected with Kovac 19 not
knowing will the CDC be publishing I
think that I think they'd probably be
willing to give that right yeah we could
get you that information Jeff mr.
president OPEC is meeting on Thursday
and you have said that they are willing
to make a cut in production if the u.s.
chips in as well which suggests that
they want you to ask US producers to do
enough show me that I don't know we'll
have to make that decision and maybe we
will maybe we won't but we'll have to
make that decision but you I think the
cuts are automatic if you're a believer
in markets
I can guarantee you there's a cut from
pre this condition you know look this
happened because of the virus the virus
knocked out 40 percent it was it went
down in one hour I mean literally when
places close up you're talking about
a 40% cut no I think it's happening
automatically but nobody's asked me that
question yet so we'll see what happens
is that you would call it you know
Thursday evening
that's the deal what's in it but you
would consider asking us companies or
they just automatic because they're
already cutting I mean you've you look
they're cutting back because it's its
market it's demand its supply and demand
they're already cutting back and they're
cutting back very seriously but if OPEC
is asking for a single problem nobody so
if they ask me I'll make a decision okay
but I'll but again it's happening anyway
yes please in light of all the
discussion about Prime Minister Johnson
and his health and can you update us on
the status of the second half of your
physical that you were going to have
this year yeah so I had a physical or
the first half was very successful I did
it on a day when I was in the White
House and we were able to do that as the
doctor reported and I have some the
second half of the physical different
probably has done it Walter Reid and
I'll do that at the appropriate time but
I feel very good and according to the
doctor a very good shape I just asked
you again on the idea of a national stay
at home recommendation what is giving
you so much pause about he understood
very well I appreciate your
understanding both the Constitution of
the United States and I'd rather have if
possible for the governors to make the
decision if a decision was very
necessary and they have done a good job
and Tony said it better than anybody
they are they are doing they are doing
what we're asking them to do without
having to put the seal on it but I will
say if I thought it was necessary I'll
do it in a heartbeat free with the
Georgia governor's I
beaches opening what the beaches I
haven't seen I'm gonna have to see to
what extent I'm gonna have to see how
many people you're talking about are
they crowded are they packed
are they not packed we'll have to take a
look at it right now it's very early for
beaches in Georgia so right now very
early so I'll take a look at it
he's done a very good job as the
governor he knows what he's doing but
we'll have to take a look it really does
depend on you know how crowded it may be
but I will talk to him and I will ask
him that question I would ask and the
airlines have been cutting their routes
you saw that yesterday they announced
big cuts and routes we need some some
flights for emergency use for military
people we need some flights for medical
people and there are very few flights as
you know and the flights that are going
out or I think they said they're 3 to 4
percent full you have 3 percent of the
plane that's occupied so it's they're
very very generally very very empty
planes but it's good to have it's a it's
a tiny amount of flights relative to the
overall and we need them also for
medical workers for otherwise we're
gonna have to do a whole big thing with
our own planes so that they're done for
a reason there's also testing done when
people get onto those planes and also
when people get off the planes follow up
on this question of the HHS Inspector
General by the way her name is Kristy
grim and it wasn't so much her opinion
but they interviewed 323 different
hospitals I'm still good their opinion
when was she appointed when was she
appointed
I'm not sure when she was would you do
me a favor let me know now I have to
know now John let me know because we are
doing an incredible job in testing we
are doing a better job than anybody in
the world right now in testing there's
nobody close and other nations admit
this other nations have admitted it very
strongly other nations are calling us
wanting to know about our testing let me
know when she was appointed would you
specific I had what he was saying was
there
way in the okay thank you very much
light coming from China full of medical
supplies companies like far away and
Alibaba has been donating the United
States million and ninety five months
and also a lot of medical gloves and
much more medical supplies it sounds
like a statement more than a question
Chinese ambassador to 80 and hi last
night Rhoda of ads on York Times calling
to cooperation with the United States so
are you personally working directly with
China beside the trade deal it's the
biggest deal probably ever made and I
hope they're gonna honor that trade deal
if they don't honor the trade deal then
I'll tell you a different answer but I
think they will they're gonna spend
billions of dollars for agriculture
they're gonna spend billions of dollars
for many different things whereas China
never spent money in our country we
spent money we had a deficit a trade
deficit with China four years of 500
billion dollars four hundred billion
dollars we had the biggest trade
deficits in the history of the world
with China now China's going to spend a
lot has agreed to spend 250 billion many
billions of dollars in our country much
of it going to farmers and manufacturers
so I'll let you know I mean I I hope
they're gonna honor the deal well for
China I work for China are you with a
newspaper who you with is it all by
China or is it owned by the state okay
okay look I'll let you know I'll give
you a good answer to that in a few
months I wanted to see what they do
because it's time for them to help us
okay it's time right now for China to
help us and hopefully they do and if
they don't that's okay too but we signed
a deal it was signed in with great
goodwill and spirit and it's time that
our farmers benefited
manufacturers benefitted and we'll see
whether or not that deal is honored and
I think it will be because I know
President Xi who I like and respect and
I think he will honor the deal he made
with us it just went into effect four
days ago I will see whether or not in
fact I called up just a little while ago
I said how the farmers doing with
respect to China are they buying the
product as anticipated and the answer
was yeah I think so but it wasn't the
most positive but it was it was starting
it was the deal just started so I'll let
you know but you know for many many
years China ate our lunch because we had
people in this position that I'm in
right now that allowed China to get away
with absolute murder and it should have
never happened but we are we are now
dealing with China we'll see what
happens to your question you must be she
was appointed in January of this year to
her current position as the principal
deputy inspector again we're gonna take
a look at you said that businesses have
applied for 40 billion dollars in loans
but can you tell us how much of that
money has actually gone out to the small
businesses I can't tell you but I know
it goes out very quickly once the loan
application is approved and the process
is very fast and you have to understand
these are banks and that's what they do
but they were swamped they were actually
swamped okay go ahead I know you don't
want to talk about the Inspector General
report but testing is still a big issue
in this country what when can hospitals
of the Spanish what if again blue
to receive a quick turnaround you ready
you ready
hospitals can do their own testing also
states can do their own testing states
are supposed to be doing testing
hospitals are supposed to be doing
testing do you understand that with the
federal government listen to with the
federal government we're not supposed to
stand on street corners doing testing
they go to doctors they go to hospitals
they go to the state the state is a more
localized government you have 50 of them
and they can go 50 within you you also
have territories as you know and they do
the testing and if you look at the chart
if you take a look did they put it up
yeah just take a look and these are
testing and the results are now coming
in very quickly initially speaking the
tests were old obsolete and not really
prepared we have a brand new testing
system that we developed very quickly
and that's your result and you should
say congratulations great job instead of
being so horrid in the way you ask a
question please go ahead so I can talk a
little bit more about testing later on
but as the president said 1.79 million
tests have been done and this does not
count the hundreds of thousands of tests
that are done within hospitals that are
now currently not reporting so I'm sure
were well over two million that
Inspector General report was done here
during our ramp up period um quite a
long time ago there was clearly and it's
hard to interpret the report because it
mixes up all kinds of things but clearly
there was complaints by some hospitals
of a backlog probably had sent out tests
and and that is true there were several
days of backlog at some of the major
labs that have been taken care of we
know now that the AC la labs now have a
24 to 48 hour turnaround they're doing
well over a hundred thousand tests a day
we now have the Abid machine that's
point-of-care that's 18 thousand of
those instruments throughout the country
the Cepheid machine is now all of
the country with a 45-minute turnaround
so we have worked directly with many of
the hospitals that have their own
laboratory derived tests some of those
really quite frankly didn't understand
the regulatory freedom they have to use
other different kinds of instruments or
different kinds of reagents so like they
do now like they do now and I'm on the
phone with them all the time to make
sure that everything is clear we have a
24-hour call number but that's what it
was it was there for and I don't know
the inspector-general I don't know that
person I tell you one thing I have a
problem with if there was such a problem
that she knew about or he knew about on
March 23rd and 24th why did I find out
about the tests from them on the on the
news media at 8 o'clock this morning if
there was a problem I think your ethical
II obliged to tell me where that is so
we can interact with it like I do every
single day but that's a discussion for
the future I think testing is really in
a good position right now and I'm be
happy to expand on some of the really
good tests that are coming up in the
previous segment you mean the Obama
administration thank you for telling me
that see there's a typical fake news
deal you know I told you what she was
before your third your race reporter and
what you just said is a disgrace okay
you asked me you said sir just gotta
point it take a look at what you said
now I said when did they when did this
person how long in governor well it was
appointed in the Obama administration
thank you very much John thank you very
much you will never make it go ahead but
can you tell us today how many
ventilators are in the federal stock
well I'm not going to tell you how many
are in the stockpile but I can tell you
that we look at ventilator use
granularly
every single day in every single state
and down to the hospital level so we
have been able to meet and easily meet
all the ventilator requirements that
have been brought us to us by the state
no one has not gotten a ventilator that
needs a ventilator and as far as we can
project looking at all models every
person who needs a ventilator will get a
ventilator I'm a ventilator doc right
I'm an ICU physician for children spent
every day of my life managing people on
ventilators this is my community it's
also the Surgeon General's community as
an anesthesiologist so what we have in
the stockpile I think is not a number
that we we give out but we have
thousands remaining in the stockpile and
now you're seeing either out of the
appropriate American spirit that when a
state like Washington or California
doesn't need that ventilator they're
doing the right thing by moving them
around the country about 9,000 just so
you understand that's about 9,000 and by
the way you didn't tell me also that
this Inspector General came out of
[Music]
quickly here I'm looking at the
Inspector General's bio she of certain
government since 1999 does hoping to ask
you about that your call with former
Vice President Joe Biden is there
something that you learned on that phone
call and has that change no I understood
his use before the call in about
speaking to people I just think he's
very nice I think he's a nice man I've
always thought he was a nice man I've I
don't know him I don't know if I ever
spoke to him before other than to say
hello but I think he's a nice man we had
a very nice cool
see now the counsel of some of your
predecessors first no not really
we miss we do it a great job hey I
inherited we this administration we
inherited a broken system both
militarily
well we've rebuilt our military well we
now have so much ammunition where as you
remember a very important general said
sir we have no ammunition they want to
save money on ammunition they didn't
want to save money because they spent
money like nobody ever spent money but
you know what we now have a great
military built that we have so much
ammunition we don't know what to do with
it okay and that's a nice feeling to
have but they also gave us empty
cupboards the cupboard was bare you've
heard the expression the cupboard was
bare so we took over a stockpile
where the cupboard was bare and where
the testing system was broken and old
and we redid it and frankly it would be
okay for a small event but not for a big
event and they had a chance to do it
somebody said that a certain person I
won't tell you but a certain person said
this will happen and that's true the
problem is that person never did
anything about it previous
administration's in previous cinema they
never did anything about it you know we
all know all about pandemics and all of
the things that we're seeing now but
nobody thought it was going to happen
and if we did think it was going to
happen
the problem is nobody did anything about
it we did we have rebuilt the system and
now we're a fine-tuned machine we built
thousands of hotel beds for New York we
moved a ship in that now we're going to
make four Kovac Kovac 19 we are going to
make it so that people having this
horrible thing happened to them will be
able to use the ship the ship as I said
is going to be shared with New Jersey
New York and New Jersey we've done
things that are incredible when you
build what was it 18 hospitals we built
18 hospitals we built Medical Center's
all over the country and when you have
gavin newsom and other governors who
really have been very nice and generous
in their statements because they make
the statements to the press not just in
my face others tell us how great we're
doing like the call that my cat did I
heard from other people there one the
koi said it was incredible was two hours
and was everything was positive they
were so happy with what we've done and
we're ready to do more if they need it
because we're ready to March the Admiral
can tell you we are sitting there with
9000 ventilators and we're ready to
March when we see that we can move very
quickly as soon as we see that need we
can move very quickly we're ready to
March we built a great system the
problem is the Democrats like a guy like
Chuck Schumer's a total lightweight by
the way I've known him for a long time
he'll say why don't you put a military
man in charge the military man I have
all military men this man is doing an
incredible job we have two Admirals
numerous generals we have the Army Corps
of Engineers we have FEMA we have this
whole force that like nobody has ever
seen before we have a great
Terry operation and they've done an
incredible job and honestly people
should respect because nobody's ever
seen anything like what we've done and
what they end up with thinking about me
don't worry about me I get I will only
get bad if I say how many ventilators do
you need governor a thousand would be
great I said no problem gonna send you
10,000 and then you'll call up from the
media you'll say how did Trump do we're
not happy he didn't send us enough
ventilators because that's called
politics but if you look at what's
happening that and I'm even surprised
the governors are saying all good things
but the Democrat governors and a couple
of rhinos frankly they're rhinos so they
are one Rhino in particular but the
governors are saying great things he had
called it last two two hours today I
heard about they call not just for Mike
it was a perfect call now I'm sure you
were on the call even though you're not
supposed to be I'm sure you were on the
call meaning some of the media was on
the call because they're constantly
reporting the call if they're honest
they will say it was a great call okay
okay next question
[Music]
you mentioned the number times
previously there seems to be some
concern in Texas that they might lose
the hospital in Dallas if it's not we're
only we're only helping Texas by the way
the governor is doing a great job over
there with this situation
and Texas is so big you have some parts
of the state that are affected other
parts that aren't affected at all you
know it's an incredible place
keep this hospital unit that's unused or
is the Fallon government going to shift
those resources elsewhere
no we're gonna use whatever we need and
we're doing it totally in conjunction
with the governor okay we're doing it in
conjunction with your Texas governor's
done a fantastic job it also has set up
checkpoints at the border
to check people coming from Louisiana
you've seen checkpoints and Florida
other state borders Americans very few
people are coming through our border and
you'll be happy to know we're up to mile
161 of the wall internal borders between
states on the border between Mexico we
have 161 miles of wall Americans don't
they're not used to seeing border
checkpoints between states
how much longer first you want us to
call eight governors and tell them to do
something and then you're complaining
that another governor is so strict that
he actually checks the borders I
understand why he's doing that because
he knows who he has and he doesn't want
people coming in if they should maybe
you know not be - these are the like
info of the doctors no I think it's look
he's done a great job he's done a great
job with this case as have many other
governors but he's done a great job one
of the things I thought you're gonna say
is we've been very tough on our southern
border as you know very very tough and
mortar that's because of the fact that
we have so much you know when you talk
about a hundred and sixty miles of new
wall nobody's coming through that nobody
not even close and we're building it
rapidly we will have early next year
we'll have close to 500 miles of wall
which is what our goal was
you mentioned Senator Schumer distant
ago he had a conference call today and
he said that he believes that a Kovach
for relief bill will be necessary do you
share that belief and what would be
contained
I don't know necessarily but I certainly
want to listen and what I want to do is
two things
a real infrastructure not a green new
deal you know the carbon footprint I'm
not looking for the carbon footprint we
want to put people to work but a real
and frankly for so many years we've let
our infrastructure go to hell because we
were wasting all our money in the Middle
East and other places okay I want to
rebuild our country I don't want to
rebuild that we're tired we've built
we've rebuilt if you call it that or
destroyed frankly what we've done is so
crazy what we have done the direction
that this country has taken is so sad
but we're in the Middle East for 8
trillion dollars and if you want to fix
a pothole in a highway you can't do it
because they don't want to give you the
funds so we want to have an
infrastructure bill a real one like in
the vicinity of two trillion dollars to
completely rebuild our roads our bridges
our highways our our tunnels everything
and I'm totally open to listening to
that I'm also open to listening to and
and even putting forward because we're
going to be putting something forward
more money for our citizens because
they've gone through a trauma this has
been trauma this came out of nowhere
when and I say it and I'll say it again
we had the greatest economy and the
history of the world we had the most
people working in the history of our
country almost a hundred and sixty
million people far more than ever before
and then one day our professionals
correctly came to us and they said sorry
sir we have to close down our country
and I said say it again say it again we
have to close down our country and the
entire world closed down because of this
hidden enemy no we were going to take
good care of our people it was not their
fault man I asked dr. burr to clarify
something that she said on Saturday if
I'm a doctor Brooks this is a question
that comes from a radio colleague of
mine Tamara Keith on Saturday it sounded
like you said that for the next week
people in high-risk areas should not
even go to the market or the drugstore
is that what you meant to say where is
that accurate you know out of respect
for every single healthcare worker
that's on the front line whether they're
a nurse a doctor a respiratory therapist
the phlebotomist the persons who come in
the rooms to clean you know out of
respect for them we as Americans should
be doing everything possible and what I
meant was if you can consolidate if you
can send one person the entire family
doesn't need to go out on these
occasions
we really need this is a highly
transmittable virus we've been saying
that we want every American to know that
what they're doing is making a
difference but we need to have
solidarity of commitment from everyone
to really so you know maybe once every
two weeks we can do a grocery store in
pharmacy shop for the entire family so
it was really about we have to do
everything we can I know I see on the TV
stations the level of human suffering in
the hospitals dr. Falchi and I and
Admiral Gerar has spent our lives taking
care of others we need to take care of
each other now as Americans and do
everything that's in those guidelines
and I know they're tough I know
incredibly how tough they are my
grandchild of ten months got a fever of
105 this weekend I'm the doctor and I
couldn't get there I mean so I'm trying
to explain to my daughter how to listen
to our lungs listen to her lies you
can't you can't take that kind of risk
with the leaders of the country grandson
just a daughter but she's but you know
we're all and that's just an
illustration that I know you all are
making sacrifices and I guess I want
everyone to take this seriously so that
was really a call of seriousness of how
important this is and how we're starting
to see the impact but you can see what
can happen when you come at this a
little bit too late and that's why the
message before you see it before you
have to see your hospitals and your
emergency rooms overwhelmed it is on us
as a member of this community of this
country to do everything possible to
save one another and so that was really
what I was saying and I will continue to
say that because I do believe it's
making a difference you can start to see
it making a difference but we have to do
even more right now
because that will predict where we are
two or three weeks from now
I saw where Governor Cuomo was a little
bit upset today over the weekend a lot
of people outside and they were they
were pretty good big groups of people I
saw that I noticed that it he wasn't
happy with that and I could understand
that look we have a period a short
period of time
hopefully it's a short period of time to
go and let's get it done let's get it
done
Kristen did you have a quick followed to
the question about legislation I know
there's discussion about a face for what
are you also looking seriously at a
second round of direct payments and are
you putting discussions on a potential
face for on hold for now while you see
that well I was opposed to the way of
distribution money distribution through
as you know unemployment and through the
state offices because they have very old
come not all of them but many of them
have 40-year old equipment as I've said
and it makes it very difficult but
that's what they're looking that's what
they want to do that's the way it's
mandated to do I thought it would be
better if we did a direct payment system
but the Democrats really wanted it and I
think they had some some help from a
couple of people that I would have had I
spoken to him I would have convinced him
otherwise I really believe but so but
it's getting out and the federal
government has done its job all we can
do is give this massive amount of money
to the states the states then are
responsible to distribute it a little
bit like we're talking about here but
the money will be right on time from the
federal government then the states have
to do their job in getting it in we
could very well do a second round of
direct I would do it direct it is
absolutely under serious consideration
in terms of truck Schumer he also said
he spoke to your chief of staff about
potentially appointing a Tsar to oversee
the supply chain is that something that
you have people that are so talented I
know the people he suggested they're
wonderful people they worked here
they're wonderful people he's just doing
that because it's politics because you
know we have many depending on what in
terms of testing this gentleman right
here in term you know who the point
person is this gentleman right here he's
the one in charge of the test was but
Mike you may want to tell him about them
because this is really a military
operation the supply chain it's a very
good question and I spoke to Senator
Schumer night before last about just
that when the president signed a
declaration of national emergency he
stood up FEMA is the lead agency
implementing his policy to marshal a
whole-of-government response and under
FEMA we provide federal support the
state manages the health care response
and health care providers and first
responders implement that response on a
local level our lead on this issue and
implementing it is administrator Pete
Gaynor but the man managing all of the
supplies and you heard a presentation
this weekend about our air bridge what
we also call the control tower we we
literally with with Admiral John pull up
chick at the helm of our logistics
effort we have visibility now on all the
supplies that are moving across this
country and into this country from
around the world it really is
extraordinary I mean when the president
tapped FEMA to lead this effort he we
essentially wanted to say we want to
organize this in a military fashion and
we tapped really someone who is widely
regarded as the number one supplies and
logistics military officer to do just
that he really is an extraordinary
individual ad murderers knowing for a
long time and to be working with Admiral
pelagic we speak every morning our team
reviews that data we go over that with
with administrator Gaynor and Admiral
pelagic we talk about an extensive team
that's identifying supplies around the
country and around the world and then as
we were explaining to governor's today
we work with the requests that are
coming in from States with a priority on
the areas that are dealing with
widespread outbreak like the the Greater
New York City area in New Jersey a
Louisiana focus on Detroit focus on
Chicago in Illinois and then what what
feat gainer and Admiral pelagic are
doing is directing those commercial
distributors to send the resources
directly to the front lines of the
battle against the coronavirus it is an
extraordinary system and as I explained
to the governors today as I've explained
to congressional leaders who've made up
what I think is a good faith
recommendation that we have that we
organized this in a manner of military
logistics it's exactly what President
Trump has done and it's what we're doing
every single day to make sure that
health care workers to make sure that
the states that are dealing with a
widespread outbreak corona' virus can be
confident that we're gonna spare no
expense leave no stone unturned and use
this extraordinary apparatus centered in
FEMA to get the people of our country
what they need when they need it to
battle the coronavirus
and Kristin when Schumer makes a
statement like that he's only done it
for politics he knows we have the best
generals the best Admirals we have the
best people these are incredible leaders
these of vibrant people they've done
such a good job and again you'll get a
tape of the conversation because I'm
sure some of the governor's probably had
their favorite reporter listening to the
conversation even though they weren't
supposed to but that's happened before
just so you understand we had a call
today that was a beautiful call
everybody friendly everybody happy they
also know in some cases we'll get them a
little bit more and if they need it
we'll get them a lot more depending on
where this monster is going
but when Schumer does does that take a
look take a look at the past well you're
gonna have to tell me great that they
certainly dog well yeah some Democrats
because they view this as a campaign
issue they want to make Trump look as
bad as they can because they want to try
and win an election that they shouldn't
be allowed to win based on the fact that
we have done a great job
we built the greatest economy in the
world I'll do it a second time we got
artificially stopped by a virus that
nobody ever thought possible and we've
handled it and we've built a team and we
built an apparatus that's been
unbelievable take a look at the swine
flu right that's h1n1 take a look at
that and it's not the other way around
by the way it's h1n1 take a look you
know what I mean by that take a look at
the swine flu it was a disaster 17,000
people died the other administration
said no it was like they didn't even
know it was here and that was peanuts
compared to what we have in terms of the
power the magnitude of what we're going
through this is attacking 182 countries
simultaneously so Schumer's just all
about politics I've known him almost all
of my adult life and he's a disgrace in
many ways he's a disgrace and he knows
it's done he just wants to do that but
he knows the job we're doing everybody's
amazed at the job we're doing and the
public is starting to find out this
start you know one of the reasons I do
these news conferences because if I
didn't
they would believe fake noose and we
can't let them believe fake news they
see us up here they see us with Admirals
they see us with this talent they see
the job that Mike Pence has done which
has been an unbelievable job an
unbelievable job I put him there
I thought he'd do well he did great as
the governor of Indiana and I thought
Mike would do well he's done much better
than well and he gets along with people
I think much better than I do because I
like people being 100 Mike can put up
with things that sometimes I say it's
amazing that he can put up with it but
he's done an incredible job and so has
the entire team this is a military
operation and again we built two
thousand nine hundred beds in Javits
Center we we build Medical Center's in
New York in Chicago we built a thousand
beds much more now in McCormick Place
that's their big convention home the
equivalent of Javits conventional big
McCormick place fantastic place by the
way the mayor of Chicago at least on the
phone is extremely happy with what we're
doing thanking us has a great
relationship with Mike thanking us and I
just wish the politicians would say to
you what they say to us really and it's
a good question
do you have one you have please
the national security front to the
extent that you can comment on this your
administration is making heavy
preparations to move against the policy
in Latin America right now and I kid you
said what America yes if you expand on
the reasoning why now are there supply
logistics especially meat isn't
political what's the reason good
question we've moved a tremendous number
of boats and ships to the area of you
know different areas of exactly where
you're talking about because we are
tired of drugs pouring into our country
from other places and we're tired of
seeing drugs pouring into different
parts of Latin America South America and
just coming into our country now we've
got them stopped at the border and
they're trying to do it by sea so we
stop them at the border with and frankly
with the help of Mexico milk Mexico
right now is twenty seven thousand
soldiers on our southern border they
never had any soldiers they're doing
that because I've asked them to do it
that's the only reason they're doing it
they have twenty-seven thousand soldiers
so now they're trying to bring it in by
boat and by ship the drug lords and the
people doing drugs and trying to destroy
our country from inside with drugs and
we're hitting them very very hard and
that's why is it beyond our context
there are the activities of human
trafficking and especially with respect
to women and as you know proportionally
it's mostly women and it's a horrible
thing it's a horrible thing and there's
never been a time like it and it's
because of the internet and this is all
over the world but for the most part
they're coming through in this country
they're coming through the southern
border but we're hitting them very hard
they have tremendous illegal trafficking
and women and children also but mostly
in women and it's illegal and it's
horrible and it's disgraceful and I've
seen things that are an absolute
disgrace and we're trying to knock them
out and when knocking him hard and again
I want to thank the President of Mexico
because he has really stepped up to the
plate 27
and soldiers they've never had any
soldiers on our border and I did that
because the Democrats will not approve
anything to stuff because they want to
have open borders they want to have all
these people flowing through our border
and in many cases they're sick they have
problems that you don't want to know
about or they're criminals in many cases
not in all cases but in many cases and
they don't want to have what they won't
have open borders they want to have
sanctuary cities so they protect
criminals and I don't want to have it
and Joe Biden doesn't want to have that
also as you know because he said that
during numerous debates I want to have
strong borders and I don't like
protecting criminals with sanctuary
cities but we're doing it for drugs
we're doing it for human trafficking
we're doing it because you have to do it
we have borders or we don't have a
country question of antibody testing
which is FDA approved now but not widely
available yet I know if the Admiral said
by May you expect to have millions
available how are you gonna prioritize
who's gonna get the antibody tests and
what does what is that going to show you
you think that's gonna be a movie
so let me clarify and I know you
probably understand this is the antibody
test does not tell you if you have the
active virus in your nose if you're a
positive for the antibody it strongly
implies it means that you have had the
virus before and to the degree that we
know of medical knowledge you will
probably highly probably be protected
against getting the virus again in the
future so I want to make something clear
on there's no antibody test approved
okay approved is not a word we talk
about there is a test or two that has
received emergency use authorization and
many many many others out there that
have not gone that way yet
and I want to take this opportunity to
caution there is a very consolidated
effort between the FDA CDC NIH to
validate some of the tests that are on
the market right now because it is very
important that they actually do what
they say they do and we have reason to
believe that not all of them are going
to perform
well I don't know the primary source but
the Financial Times just reported that
the UK had seventeen point five million
antibody tests that they bought and none
of them work so we're not going to get
in that situation we're going to be very
careful to make sure that when we tell
you you're likely immune from the
disease you're really that test really
said that now I will also make a
statement and I'm there's a lot of work
on here and I'm very excited about it as
opposed to the test for a novel virus
the antibody type tests are very
sophisticated technology but they're all
technology this we expect to have many
tens of millions of tests the first
month that we are really sure that the
test makes sense so this this allows for
surveillance screening and dr. Burks is
one of the world experts to understand
is one percent five percent twenty
percent of Americans have been infected
but it also allows us to have very
widespread tens and tens of millions of
people screened with a finger prick on
the spot so so we're science doesn't run
on rails right so we need to make sure
that the FDA the NIH which they're
actively doing right now
assure that the tests that they're
testing really do with perform the way
they should and if things work out the
way we believe they will we will have
millions on the market by May in a
sophisticated way in a prospective way
that we get the surveillance we need we
can test people to see if they've been
exposed immune and go back to work and a
combination of that kind of test with
the current kind of tests we have now is
how America opens back up against those
tests I mean tens of million we're a
country of 300 million how do you
determine who you're going to have well
we were having active discussions under
the leadership of dr. Burks in the task
force but you can imagine how that is
right but with tens and tens and tens of
millions of tests per month that are
available you could really do wide very
widespread testing but let me just give
you an example nobody else no other
country can do I just give you one
example it would be very important to
know if the virus is still circular
here whether for example a healthcare
worker or a long-term care nursing home
worker is immune from the virus and
can't carry it very very important to
protect our elderly in that situation
but also if you haven't been exposed to
make sure that you really take
precautions and maybe take care of the
people who don't have the virus and you
don't have the virus so they're very
it's complex but it's not complicated on
how you go about looking this in
different segments of society and I
don't want to take too much more time at
the podium but antibody tests are a
different thing
they're coming we're highly confident
that this can be scaled very rapidly and
provide us a bit of information we just
don't have now and then Mike is taking
over and you're going to see some
incredible work that's been done please
follow up on what you said with regard
to captain Crozier before you say you
didn't want to punish him for having a
bad day bad day would be a bad week does
that but I don't yeah I want to I'm
going to look into it and I I also I
also think our Devi Secretary's highly
respected man so sometimes that happens
with people and I'll take a look at it
what do you mean by that would you
consider reasoning he sends a letter out
and he sends copies all over the place
and it's not a classified letter and it
was very disconcerting to the families
of the people on the ship were very
disconcerting so number one they get
worried and scared it was weak we don't
want weak but I'm gonna take a look
because he's I think he you know looks
to me like he's an outstanding guy I
looked I looked at his home just a
little while ago I looked at his file
and people have bad days and we'll take
a look at it question is what would you
consider doing for him well we'll take a
look I want to look I want to speak also
to the secretary I also want to speak to
Secretary of Defense who's mark Esper is
doing a fantastic job and we'll you know
maybe I can help the situation out I
mean you guys are saying why is the
president getting involved in
well I like to sell problems it's a
problem you know I don't want to see men
hurt women hurt I don't want to see
people hurt unnecessarily maybe we can
solve it easily where you know it's not
life changing but he did he did a bad
thing
sending a letter out and many many
copies as you know I don't know I heard
28 copies I heard a lot that's a lot of
copies plus the letter was five pages
long I haven't read the letter but I
think was five pages long single spaced
that's a lot of writing you know he's
the captain of a ship he's the he's a
very important person of a very
expensive ship a nuclear-powered ship he
should be writing letters like that but
it happens sometimes I'll write a letter
that I say I wish I didn't send it not
too often but it happens try one more
time he did say in remarks to soldiers
on the USS Roosevelt that closure was
quote too naive or too stupid to be in
command if he didn't think that way well
I don't know what he said I understand
language but I don't want it let's not
get into that it's tough language there
are some people that they go Wow
he says it like it is look she made a
mistake he should not have sent that
letter or he should have gone through
his chain of command which is the
typical way of doing it you know he's in
the military is a very important person
in the military he knows it better than
anybody in this room what he should have
done and I'm sure he feels he made a
mistake but I'm gonna look into it and
I'm gonna see maybe we can do something
cuz I'm not looking to destroy a
person's life who's had an otherwise
stellar career as I understand it I
looked at this file just now because
I've been seeing what's going on if we
can save if we can save a person's
career I don't mind going after a person
if they did something wrong and you know
but this was a mistake he made a mistake
I'm not justifying what he did he made a
mistake shouldn't be sending letters
he's the captain he's a very important
person in the military you don't say the
letters and then it'll leaks and
a newspaper of all newspapers that was a
beauty right so you just don't do that
so it was a mistake but I may get
involved
I'll call Secretary of Defense and find
out a little bit about it and if I can
help to people to good people I'm gonna
help them I said when you asked me and
when the question was asked the last
time I said shouldn't have sent the
letter I haven't changed he shouldn't
understand a letter and it should if
there's a letter it should go classified
and it should go to his superior and he
shouldn't be jumping up and said so he
hasn't changed in that regard the only
thing that has played right up here with
me is that I looked at his record and
he's been an outstanding person if he
wasn't I wouldn't even be talking about
this he's been an outstanding person
he's had a very exemplary military
career I mean you know he started off as
a helicopter pilot they called him
chopper his name was chopper was a great
helicopter pilot it's a tremendous skill
I know a lot about helicopters and then
he went to f-16s or f-18s and he was a
tremendous pilot and then he's very
smart
he studied nuclear energy and he was
fantastic and very few people have the
aptitude they have the mentality to do
that nuclear energy is very complex very
it's very hard very few people can do it
and he did it well and then it became
the captain of a nuclear ship right he
became of a if a replacement course if
you look at replacement cost 18 billion
dollars a replacement cause wait so he's
got on a replacement cause basis an 18
billion dollar ship you know the
President Gerald Ford very expensive
that's you know the nearest thing I can
think of but they're spending money on
that was like nobody's ever seen so he
made a mistake he made a mistake and
maybe we're gonna make that mistake not
destroy his life
even you mentioned medical professionals
you compared them to soldiers going on
the battlefield yeah many doctors and
medical workers today sometimes the pay
cuts they're going into a certain
environment where they're concerned
about their own health their families
and a livelihood if something were to
happen to very much a moment as part of
this phase four are you going to see
phase four I think it could be a
separate phase when it's all over right
now I don't think they want to think
about these people don't want to think
about these people are incredible
they're not thinking about how much am I
getting paid these people are incredible
I've seen it I see the spirit I hear
about it all the time from Mike from the
Admiral I hear about it all the time
these people are incredible when it's
all over I do want to seriously think
maybe in the form of bonuses these
people are what they've done is
incredible I just I just admire the
attitude and I've said it I just did
they walk into those hospitals and they
are seriously you know one of the things
that came up with the comfort the ship
is that when we fulfilled the request of
Governor Cuomo and Governor Murphy and
they're going to be splitting up but you
know a lot of things happen to ships
when you do that you know it's a lot of
they didn't want to do this in fact they
specifically didn't want to do this have
patients that were affected with this
horrible disease or whatever had the
plague because frankly it's a plague
that's exactly what it is you'd read
about it in the old days the plague and
that's exactly what it is but we're
doing it but when I see the bravery of
these people walking through doors
without their self I mean they're
halfway just getting within they're not
standing outside hey let's get ready
let's they're running through doors
putting on the stuff it's not even one I
think it's incredible I'm telling you
the nearest thing I can think of is
soldiers in battle and children's going
right into battle because that's what
they're doing it's really in many ways
it's the same thing all right how about
one more question
you may have seen this the Masters
Tournament that's been rescheduled to
November two questions hey is that an
outgrowth of your conversation that you
had with sports ignition rosanna I hope
I hope footballs able to start I hope
baseball can get to play a little bit I
hope basket book and maybe do their
playoffs I mean hey I have no I have no
interests or anything other than I want
what's good for the country a lot of
people are tired any times yeah a lot of
people are tired of looking at games
that are five years old I look the other
day I saw somebody I said well he looks
great
forgot I said oh that was nine years ago
yet I said he's really a great shape
well not a great shape now but he was in
great shape then it was nine years ago
you know you get tired of looking at
nine year old baseball games and in
playoff games it took place 12 years ago
I don't have much time to do that
frankly but that's what people are doing
and they want to see sports sports are a
great thing for this country and I hope
football can start and I told them I
think you might be able to they may very
well be able to I hope they can start
and I hope they can start with people in
the stands you know we're not going to
be separated but you have seats those
seats are meant for people to sit next
to each other and when this virus is
gone people are going to be sitting next
to each other and just for the
restaurant industry so they understand
when the virus is gone people are going
to be sitting next to each other one man
said I have a 200 seat restaurant it's
been great but if I go by these rules
this 200 seats goes down to 60
I said don't know you have a 200 seat
restaurant that's what you have but we
have to wait till the virus goes away it
wouldn't even do well at 60 frankly
there's a warmth to it also if there's a
warmth but not when we have the virus in
the air
well ladies and gentlemen thank you very
much so I'm going to let our Vice
President take over he's got some really
interesting numbers statistics and I
want to thank the Admiral I want to
thank Tony and Debra and everybody else
I want to thank everybody that's working
and I really do I see a lot of
tremendous things happen at the
therapeutics the call I had today was
one of the most exciting calls I've had
in a long time and again I want to wish
my best to the UK and
the family of Boris Johnson and we just
hope he's going to be okay because he's
a fine guy thank you very much everybody
thank you
Thank You mr. president a few updates on
the activity of the White House
coronavirus task force then I'm going to
ask dr. Burks to speak about what we're
seeing in the numbers we know we are at
the beginning of what's gonna be a very
tough week in America but as dr. Burks
will reflect because the American people
have been embracing social distancing
putting into practice the advice of
state and local leaders and the
president's coronavirus guidelines for
our country as dr. Burks will describe
we are not only seeing remarkable
progress in Washington State and in
California where the numbers remain low
and steady it's a great tribute to the
people of both of those states and to
all of their dedicated health care
workers but we're also beginning we're
beginning to see a leveling and just at
the very beginning and she'll reflect on
those in just a few moments a couple of
quick updates at the present moment the
president has approved 50 major disaster
declarations and will likely be issuing
a disaster declaration for the state of
Minnesota before the end of the day
we've distributed more than four point 1
billion dollars to States and right
after our incredible health care workers
we couldn't be more proud of more than
21,000 National Guard that have been
activated and and are working in states
all across the country during my
conference call today I learned that
Governor Brian Kemp is actually using
the Georgia National Guard to sanitize
and clean up nursing homes but National
Guard are being deployed in a variety of
ways all across the country and
to them and to the families of all these
citizens soldiers you have our
admiration and our respect as the
president mentioned our focus remains on
the New York metro area in New Jersey
Louisiana and then Michigan and Illinois
we're watching every area of the country
but those are the priorities today and
in that spirit I spoke today as the
President did with Governor Cuomo of New
York the president made the decision to
open up the USNS comfort to kovat
patients and he also informed the
Governor of New Jersey that we would be
taking New Jersey kovat patients so now
there will be two facilities one of the
Javits Center that's all kovat and in
the USNS comfort there will be managing
covin patients at the present moment
there by this evening there will be a
2179 medical military personnel in New
York City and over the next two days
that number will rise to 3,000 speaking
with the governor speaking with mayor de
Blasio the President and I were informed
that while we have surged ventilators we
have surged personal protective
equipment that sending in some relief
for health care workers was vitally
important so again I want to emphasize
that that those are medical personnel
doctors and nurses and medical
assistants who are on the scene now and
will continue to arrive to a total
number of 3,000 I spoke to a governor
Phil Murphy of New Jersey New Jersey is
very much in the forefront of the corona
virus in America today we want to want
to commend the governor for his
extraordinary leadership in the state
during our briefing today we learned
about the progress that they were making
and also about the governor's decision
to temporarily reactivate retired health
care personnel in the state and just as
a reminder of
all that we're dealing with this weekend
governor Murphy told me that New Jersey
surpassed the number of lives that were
lost on September 11th to the state of
New Jersey and it breaks our heart to
think of that and our our hearts go out
to all of the families of the more than
ten thousand Americans who have
succumbed to the corona virus we also as
the president said we express our
gratitude to governor's in in Oregon and
Washington State yesterday for for
donating ventilators to help States at
the epicenter of the corona virus
governor Gavin Newsom of California
donated five hundred ventilators and I
just learned that those will be going
200 to the state of Maryland 50 to the
District of Columbia 100 to the state of
Delaware 100 to Nevada and we'll also be
deploying the remaining 50 to the
Northern Marianas Islands and to Guam
and we want to thank Governor Gavin
Newsom the state of California has
provided extraordinary and compassionate
leadership for their citizens they're
making progress there as the governor
said the other day they're not out of
the woods yet but the numbers speak for
themselves and the generosity of the
people of California and the governor is
gratefully received
beyond that before I recognize dr. Burks
let me let me just say that at the
beginning of this challenging time we
want to we want to challenge every
American to continue to do what every
American can do and clearly what we see
in Washington in California and what we
are just beginning to see elsewhere is
put into practice the social distancing
recommendations of the coronavirus
guidelines for America listen to your
state and local authorities we really do
believe that
well this will be a week of heart ache
it also is a week of hope and as we see
some of the cases beginning to level
just for a day or two it is our hope
that what we have seen begin in the
Greater New York area and even in
Louisiana and elsewhere will become a
trend but it only becomes a trend if
every one of us continues to take
ownership and continues to do our part
for this 30 days to slow the spread with
that I'll recognize dr. Burks for the
latest data and then we'll take
questions Thank You mr. vice president I
think you heard very clearly our concern
in the new york new jersey metro areas
this is also includes Connecticut and
Long Island as we talked about we did
see a significant increase in Sussex
County over the weekend the weekend
numbers are always difficult I want to
be clear on that because sometimes case
reporting is not as accurate over the
weekend so we'll be watching very
closely today's numbers and Tuesday's
numbers also very coarse focused on the
New Orleans metro area and that includes
the three parishes of Jefferson st.
John's the Baptist's and New Orleans
proper and of course the Detroit area
which is Oakland and Wayne as we
mentioned before we're continuing to
track very closely out of concerns of a
potentially reaching logarithmic phase
in the Chicago metro area the Boston
metro area the DC and Baltimore metro
area Indianapolis the Denver area and
two regions of Pennsylvania Philadelphia
and the Pittsburgh area as well as
Dallas and Houston in the Texas area I
had a very encouraging call because you
know we also don't want to miss anything
remember I showed you a lot of states
were very much under 25 and 50 cases for
a hundred thousand there were some a few
standouts that we were concerned about
which was Vermont New Hampshire Idaho
and Montana we had excellent calls today
with their health commissioners and
there really were able there on top of
the situation the
were micro outbreaks that occurred due
to ski events and weddings and nursing
homes and they were able to describe in
critical detail the incidents and how
they're tracking and tracing so they are
still doing full contact tracing through
those areas and I just want to applaud
these this both a rural and Metro
problem and I really want to applaud how
many of the states that may have smaller
populations are approaching this that
gives us encouragement of how we can
talk about beginning surveillance
activities at the same time we're
following these very clear outbreaks and
ensuring that there's full supplies
based on the very granular data that
we're utilizing and I just want to thank
the mayors and governors who get us that
granular data and allow us to make these
deep interpretations across all of
United States we know each governor is
concerned about their areas but these
metro areas cover different areas so the
Philadelphia area also includes southern
New Jersey and Delaware and so we have
to really look at things very much as
both the Metro and the communities that
surround those those metros and to all
of those people we ask you again
throughout the United States to follow
these very clear guidance I want to just
recognize both HHS and you heard about
the work that Admiral Jarrar is doing
the work that dr. Han an administrator
Seema Varma Verma are doing and also
administrator angles in the work of
hersa to really ensure that our
federally funded clinics are actively
engaged in all of these aspects but I
also want to recognize the military the
Medical Corps the nursing Corps and the
medical subspecialty core these were my
brothers and sisters for 29 years it is
highly unusual for the active force to
be called into a domestic situation I
think that shows you how seriously we're
taking this at the federal government
level in my 29 years in the military I
was never deployed domestically so this
is I'm showing you how serious of an
event we take this if the military is
deploying domestically it is
another reason for every American to be
following these guidelines
finally on CDC quietly launched a new
website it's you go to CDC gov and you
go to covet 19 you can find their
surveillance data this surveillance data
is bringing together our influenza like
illness 'as with their cinder ohmic
management databases so that you can
track the respiratory disease across the
United States the states are used to
using this system it's in emergency
rooms it's in hospitals it's in doctors
offices and it gives you insight and you
can see very clearly influenza a peak
you can see the influenza B peak and now
you can start to see the respiratory
disease from this current outbreak these
are the systems that exist within the
United States that will be strengthened
in order for us to do comprehensive
surveillance so I just want to assure
the American people while we're working
on these outbreaks we're also working on
bringing new systems together that have
a comprehensive look across the country
building on the strong work of CDC is a
public health institution so that we can
we're a county by county community by
community state by state to really
understand where this virus is and where
it will be but also as an early alert
for us in the future so I just want to
assure the American people that as we're
working on the crisis of today we're
looking to the future to ensure we have
the systems in place to bring those
early alert systems together while we
work on the antibody testing and why we
work on continuing spreading and
increasing the diagnostic capabilities
that you see presented here thank you
and Admiral DRA spoke several times when
the president was with us so he'll be
here for questions as deborah birx will
but dr. dr. foul to your thoughts and
then we'll we'll take some questions
I just wanted to it's okay I will it
related to the something I said
yesterday about that somewhat paradox of
everything going up at the same time
that the feeding into this engine of
this virus is starting to show some
signs so Governor Cuomo today reported
an interesting data from New York namely
that the number of hospitalizations the
number of admissions to intensive care
and the number of requirements for
intubations over the last three days
have actually started to level off so
again everybody who knows me knows I'm
very conservative about making
projections but those are the kind of
good signs that you look for you never
even begin to think about claiming
victory prematurely but that's the first
thing you see when you start to see the
turnaround that doesn't mean we don't
have a lot of work to do
that tells me instead of saying that's
pretty good it's we got there through
mitigation we cut off the stream of
people who ultimately require
hospitalization required intubation
required all of the kinds of extreme
methods so we just got to realize that
this is a indication despite all the
suffering and the and and the death that
has occurred that what we have been
doing has been working so the call that
I say every time I get to this podium is
just keep it up because this is going to
get us out of it this is our best and
only great public health tool you're
gonna see it most dramatically John in a
place like New York where you see it
goes up and peak and then it will
hopefully and I think it will come down
when you have places like Seattle which
did and Washington State who did a
really good job from the beginning it
never really did that so they were able
to keep it down and on the the charts
that dr. Burke showed when you saw a
California and Washington State they
were fortunate they did a good job that
it never really got out of hand so again
this is a big country and you have a
number of different metropolitan areas I
think if we do it right you're gonna see
those who have not peaked will not peak
and those who have Pete the New Orleans
the New York New Jersey Chicago Detroit
and others you're gonna see the same
thing if we keep our foot on the
accelerator I just follow up I'm just
coming from your about what what like
what's like gonna be coming back to
normal one until there's a vaccine that
there'll be gradual steps towards it
with surrogacy under that need a short
of a vaccine does putting 80,000 people
fans spectators in an in a sports
stadium worth 25,000 politicos in an
arena for a clinical convention this
summer make a lot set to this those
sorts of things are require a vaccine to
fully protecting the American populace
so I don't think that you're going to
have to say that the country cannot get
back to a real degree of them normalcy
until you absolutely have a safe and
effective vaccine it will be really
evaluating the kinds of things and
that's the reason why it was discussed
up here why it's so important to have an
antibody test so you know what the
penetrance is in society and then we
have a situation where we don't ever
want to get to have to mitigate you
wanted to be able to to contain and by
the time we have to face what's going to
happen with a with this going back to
normal t we will have them placed the
capability of identifying isolating
contact tracing so that it never gets
out of hand
ultimately the showstopper will be
obviously a vaccine where you can
vaccinate people and you won't have it
there's going to be another issue that's
going to be important and it has to do
with somewhat of a comparison for
example with influenza we go through
multiple cycles of influenza there's
always a degree of background immunity
in the population I mean that will
ultimately happen if we get a situation
where we get back to normal
now what I hope we don't have so many
people infected that we actually had
that herd immunity but I think it would
have to be different than it is right
now so again remember when you say
normalcy I mean we could get back
normally economically and otherwise
without necessarily
saying we're gonna forget about the
virus we have to pay attention to this
because we've had a very bad experience
with this virus thank you and this is
for the vice-president for doctor burse
and dr. Baumann can you give us a sense
of and I know you don't want to make any
projections but where we are with the
numbers because we saw that horrible
number today more than 10,000 deaths now
in the US are we on track for those
best-case-scenario numbers that you had
laid out the hundred thousand or are we
potentially coming in lower than that at
this point given some of what you're
seeing you know it just gives me an
opportunity to thank and respect the
modelers who have really worked on this
because there's there's a large number
of them have worked very hard and done a
lot of predictions and what we did is
did we did predictions of predictions we
like to integrate data and so that's
where you come up with these numbers I
think dr. Falchi and I both strongly
believe that if we work as hard as we
can over the next several weeks that we
will see potential to go under the
numbers that were predicted by the
models and I think that is really two
things it is the extraordinary
compliance of the American people and
the due diligence that they have
mitigated with because remember we are
doing this strictly by behavior change
it's very hard to change trajectory of
viruses on just behavior change we have
had difficulty in our past doing that on
so that's what we're doing and that's
what the American people are doing but
the other side of that is the incredible
insights that Washington State and
others are providing on how to better
care for the patients in the hospital so
those two pieces are coming together
that could have a dramatic impact on the
predictions of the mortality from this
disease so I'm glad you asked that
question because I've said it a couple
of times here I want to say it again
repetition is good is that models are
good they they help us to make
projections but as you get data in you
modify your model and I've always says
always Trump's models always so what I
feel and I believe that dr. Burks also
feels that I don't think anyone has ever
mitigated the way I'm seeing people
mitigate right now this has never
happened in this country before so I am
optimistic always cautiously optimistic
that if we do what I've been talking
about over the past few minutes we can
make that number go down
I don't accept every day that we're
gonna have to have a hundred to two
hundred thousand debts I think we can
really bring that down no matter what a
model says because when the data comes
in will start the saying you know maybe
you are essentially overshooting the
model and I think that's what we can go
that's the reason why I like to always
get up and tell the American people it's
the virus doing what the virus wants to
do and it's we as a society doing what
we can do let me just amplify that from
a lay person's perspective and the
American people are doing it I mean that
the initial data what we've seen in
California and Washington's support the
fact that the American people are doing
these things which there's nothing short
of loving your neighbor I mean the truth
is the threat of serious illness for
most Americans is relatively low but the
threat of serious illness for seniors
with with underlying health conditions
or anyone with an immunodeficiency is
very high and when when we see Americans
putting these principles into practice
the way you all have been it really
means you're considering others more
important than yourself and and I have
to tell you for the president for me for
all of us it's deeply inspiring we just
need to continue to do it for all of
these 30 days and we'll bring that
number down how about a couple more
please
when will you know when do you think
that you will know whether or not you
will have to extend those 30-day
guidelines well the the experts told us
that somewhere around the middle of this
month would be the peak and as we begin
to see a couple of days where that might
be the beginning of loveling we're gonna
we're going to watch that carefully and
we're going to bring that information to
the president but for now the decision
is and the request of every American is
to continue to put into practice all of
the president's coronavirus guidelines
30 days to slow the spread and for all
of you in areas that have been impacted
broadly by the coronavirus listen to
what your state and local authorities
are asking you to do it will protect
your health your family's health and it
will save lives let's do a couple more
and for our panel if you'd like do to
her the great care of my 91 year old
nurse mother and my daughter she's down
to like a hundred to ninety-nine now but
it was three days of a hundred and four
hundred and five which is you know
babies can do that but it's very scary
especially when I couldn't assure myself
that she was fine so it was just some
sleepless nights for me and them as they
kept her fever down so thank you for
asking
yeah no I'm sure it's roseola or
something they have not been out of the
house they are not allowed out of the
house they've got two granddaughters
under one two and a half on the Osten
one only ten months and my 91 year old
and 96 year olds so no one is allowed in
that house or out of that house because
there's too much precious cargo inside
the house
how about how about one more one more
question religious vice-president for
whoever wants to answer this it's a
technical question so famous says that
it is in the process of distributing 90%
of each state's allocated supplies from
the National strategic stockpile and
that allocation is determined based on
population by the last census in each
state and the other 10% it says is going
to frontline healthcare workers serving
in the federal response efforts so where
where are those health care workers in
the federal response and do you envision
a scenario in which you could start
giving States more supplies from the
national strategic stockpile you know
it's a really good question and let me
say the strategic national stockpile and
I'm going to have Admiral do you all
speak about his piece of that is has
been largely deployed we are continuing
to replenish it in part with a small
portion of what's coming in from around
the world you've heard about our air
bridge now more than 50 flights that
have been scheduled that are bringing
millions of supplies into the United
States what we're doing is taking less
than 10% of that put it into the
strategic national stockpile so we have
that to basically provide for States on
an as-needed basis but the other 90
percent that that system that I just
described earlier when the president was
here is working with the six major
medical distributors in the country to
deploy those resources to New York New
Jersey Connecticut Louisiana Michigan
Illinois the exact priority that you
just heard dr. Burke's described and
that the data informs and those
decisions are being made every single
day and so while well if a hurricane
hits Florida or or tornadoes or flooding
tear through the state of Indiana
we're very accustomed to FEMA coming in
drawing from the National
stockpile providing specific resources
in this case with a nationwide effort
what President Trump directed us to do
was literally marshal the resources of
the full economy to be able to make sure
that we can meet the needs for personal
protective equipment ventilators and and
all manner of supplies and we're doing
that in in a small way through the
strategic national stockpile but in the
largest way through that control tower
system that Admiral John pelagic is is
running for us that is deploying those
resources and making sure they're going
going straight to where they need to go
and as I said earlier those decisions
are being informed by the data and
they're literally being made by our team
at FEMA on a daily and sometimes hourly
basis and we'll continue to keep you
informed as we did today about where
some of those are going but let me let
emerald you all finish that answer I
don't really have much more to add to
that the Vice President is certainly
well informed about that and I want to
assure you that all the sourcing around
the world if it's there we're putting it
in our supply chains
we're buying more manufacturers are
stepping up to the plate and this is
going not just by percent allocation but
it's going to the exact places that need
it in the quantities that they need to
take care of patients and we want to
make sure this is a two-way street we
get the data in from individual
hospitals to know exactly what their
burn rate is exactly what they need and
we want to make sure that they feel
comfortable that they're going to have
supplies because they will because part
of this is about potential shortages
other place some places most of it's
about a fear of a shortage if I'm a
physician in ICU and I'm not sure that
it's gonna be there that's gonna scare
me it's gonna scare my nurses so we want
everyone to have that assurance that we
will provide you what you need over
weeks periods of time exactly to your
need and Admiral pull up Chuck and his
team and again it's all military in
there I mean he is the logistics guy for
the Joint Chiefs of Staff right this is
what he does he is a wizard he has a
whole there are more stars around me
in the in the DoD part of the military
then I've generally seen outside of the
Pentagon this is really being run as a
military operation I'm in the US Public
Health Service so we're part of HHS a
Surgeon General and I have the honor of
running that service we are
shoulder-to-shoulder in the field in the
military hospitals with everyone else
they're only six thousand one hundred of
us three thousand are doing direct
patient care on a daily basis we take
care of the Indian Health Service the
Bureau of Prisons those in detention at
the border etc that's what we do the
other 3,000 over two thousand of those
are in the field already taking care of
patients directly and we have more going
out the door every day very quickly then
is it even worse than governor's riding
into FEMA if they've already received
their 90% allocation and you're getting
data directly from the hospitals to ask
for more at this point this is this has
been a very cooperative interaction I
bet I talked to five governors a day and
we talked out we talked out the issues
and understand what they what they
perceive in their state they often help
us help point us to particular areas
that may that they feel need more
attention or there's needs more
communication so it's been very
productive I you know I I have to look
up what governor goes to what state
because I'm not that's not my world but
but it's been a very productive
interaction so I think all of this is
necessary I'm on almost every governor's
call with the vice president there very
meaningful there impactful there
informative there communicative we talk
to each other but then we do get down to
the individual hospital level because
when the rubber meets the road you got
to know what the docs nurses respiratory
therapists the people who clean the
rooms are important part of the team I
want them to come to every work saying
you know it's not that I clean the room
I'm saving lives today and they are
saving lives by keeping the viruses off
the surfaces and reducing transmission
so you've really got to get that
granular and we're to a point with
Admiral Pease you have two Admirals with
the worst pronounced names in the world
so Admiral Pierluigi but Admiral Pease
team really has this covered down to the
individual hospital
let me say just by way of closing
because I thought I thought that last
question was helpful we're interacting
with governor's every day seven days a
week and and we welcome that and while
there are some resources in the
strategic national reserve we spoke
about ventilators we have some 9,000
ventilators on standby we also have this
vast array through the commercial system
that when we hear from governor's we're
identifying the needs they're working
every day to identify their hospital
capacity we went over governor's today
saying we need to know we need to know
what your capacity is what your normal
capacity is what your surge capacity is
we need to understand what what your
equipment complement is across the state
and governor's have been doing this
they've been assembling that information
but I want to tell you that governor's
across this country in both political
parties have been doing a remarkable job
and the president is grateful and I'm
grateful and I just want to know that
those health care workers that they're
serving and the families that those
health care workers are serving can be
confident that we are going to do
whatever it takes to get them what they
need when they need it and every
governor is working in that regard every
hospital administrator is working in
that regard and the opportunity that
that we have because the American people
are stepping up so strongly and and
putting others ahead of themselves there
in most cases they're there they're
acting in a way that that puts the
health of others first we're we're more
confident today than ever before that
we're going to be able to provide our
health care providers and the states
that are impact with coronavirus with
the resources and the support they need
to meet this moment and we're just going
to continue to work our hearts out and
and make that a reality
you know I but I have to end with just a
reference to the health care workers
like you've heard these doctors talk
about them they're all health care
I heard the president talk about him you
all of soon and to think with what these
health care workers doctors and nurses
and medical assistants are doing every
day it inspires us to get up early to
stay up late to keep working to make
sure they have what they need to be able
to continue to do their job courageously
and I know I speak on behalf of every
American when I say how grateful we are
for each and every one of you and and in
this very special holy week I know
millions of Americans are praying for
our health care workers I saw a picture
that I I sent out last night on on
Twitter it was an article about a series
of cities where doctors and nurses had
paused to pray for the patients and the
families that they were ministering to
and I just want to say to all those
health care workers I know there is a
chorus of prayer going up every day for
all of you and with your continued
courageous service and with God's help
we'll get through this and we'll get
through it together thank you